>> IF THEY DON'T WANT TO TRADE
WITH US THAT'S FINE WITH ME.
WE WILL SAVE A LOT OF MONEY.
>> Laura: GORDON JOINS US.
WHERE DO YOU SEE THIS GOING?
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS IDEA IT'S
CRAZY FOR US TO TRADE WITH CHINA
AT ALL?
THE PRESIDENT FLOATED THAT
CONCEPT TODAY.
THE MARKETS WERE JITTERY THE
LAST COUPLE OF DAYS.
WHERE DO THINGS STAND NOW?
>> WELL, THINGS STAND AT A POINT
WHERE THE CHINESE ARE NOT
TALKING TO US.
AT THE G-20, THEY NEGOTIATED AN
INTERIM DEAL THAT WAS FAVORABLE
FOR CHINA.
THE CHINESE AGREED TO BUY MORE
AG-PRODUCTS.
THEY COULD NOT EVEN HONOR THAT.
IN BEIJING, THERE IS POLITICAL
PARALYSIS.
SOMETHING IS REALLY WRONG.
YOU CAN'T NEGOTIATE WITH THE
CHINESE RIGHT NOW.
TRUMP IS SAYING WE WILL GO ON
WITHOUT THEM.
THAT'S WHERE WE NEED TO BE.
DISENGAGE.
>> Laura: AND REPORTERS CAME OUT
THAT CHINA SAID IT LOOKS LIKES
IT'S MOVING TOWARDS AN EFFORT TO
DE-COUPLE FROM THE UNITED
STATES.
HOW REALISTIC IS THAT WITH
GERMANY'S ECONOMY FLAT.
FRANCE IN TURMOIL.
BREXIT STILL NOT DETERMINED.
A LOT OF TUMULT IN BRITAIN.
NO OTHER ECONOMY IS STRONG IN
THE WORLD OTHER THAN THE UNITED
STATES.
HOW DOES CHINAA DECOUPLE?
>> THEY CAN'T REALLY DECOUPLE.
LAST YEAR'S CHINA'S MERCHANDISED
IN THE U.S. WAS 103%.
WE HAVE AN ECONOMY THAT IS NOT
DEPENDENT ON CHINA BUT CHINA HAS
AN ECONOMY DEPENDENT ON US.
THAT GIVES US A LOT OF LEVERAGE.
ONE THING WE HAVE SEEN THIS